hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
right here in front of me I have the
magic keyboard case with the 2000 2011
inch iPad pro and I have Logitech's
combo touch keyboard case with the
10-point 2 inch 2019 budget iPad and in
this video we're going to be comparing
basically everything between these two
keyboard cases we're talking the
material the keyboards the track pads
the extra features that they have the
premium feel the price everything
between these two so let's get right
into it now before we begin I've got to
admit that I've been using the Logitech
for around a week right now and the
magic keyboard case over the weekend and
I've got to say that I fell in love I
expected it to be pretty good but once I
started using the trackpad the keyboard
everything together it just totally blew
me away so let's get into it so let's
start with the materials of the cases so
with the magic keyboard you have this
rubbery polyurethane kind of plastic
finish now this feels pretty nice the
only drawback is over time it starts to
get scratched up a little bit and smudge
but on the Logitech side you have like
this fabric texture and feel almost
feels like jeans but I think it's made
out of like a plastic material too so if
you spill something on it it's seems to
be like water resistant seems like it
won't get stained very easily so this
actually does feel pretty nice and what
I really like about the magic keyboard
case is how just perfectly flush it is
on both sides it's just so slim and it
just feels so premium how it just
perfectly wraps it it keeps it nice and
thin I know it's still pretty thick
compared to the iPad pro by itself but
if you compare it to this guy this this
is a thick boy like they went overboard
on how thick they made this case but to
be honest if you drop this thing I don't
think anything's gonna happen to the
iPad like it's so well protected
compared to if you drop this on the side
there's a good chance you're gonna get a
tent or a scratch in the iPad pro itself
so that's one of the drawbacks now my
number one complaint about the magic
keyboard is how hard it is to open like
you can't do it with one hand I don't
so you kind of have to like wedge your
fingers in between it and then get it up
like that or here's another way you kind
of lift it up on the hinge and you just
drop the keyboard section down just like
that
and then as you can see you can easily
adjust the angles and with face ID if
you go you're in and feels nice
now with this guy I guess you can also
put on the hinge drop the keyboard
portion and you pull back this flap
that's adjustable there you go
so if we're comparing the convenience of
the stands even though this one takes a
little bit more effort to open up I
still prefer this because there's
nothing sticking out and it just adjusts
pretty well although the Logitech can go
down a lot more like that but in reality
I don't know who's going to be using it
like that honestly this right here even
standing still I can see the display
just fine the angle is just perfectly
fine on this but either way you really
can't go wrong if you're going with the
Logitech it's fine it works I still like
it now one of the really cool benefits
with the Logitech is that you can
actually lift it up take the keyboard
off just set it down if you're watching
a movie or something else now for the
Apple pencil solutions between these two
the Logitech has this little sleeve on
top which is really nice and convenient
for the first generation of Apple pencil
so there you go it's not going anywhere
it's really sturdy inside there but for
the iPad pro you have the
second-generation Apple pencil so it
uses the wireless charging and magnetic
Connect system like that
so downside is you could lose this much
easier than you can with the 10.2 inch
iPad with the original Apple pencil
however this is the really cool part you
just hold it down and pick it up with
one hand just like that you can take it
vertically if you have some vertical
apps you want to use just use it drawing
whatever you want to do works perfectly
fine and then when you're done just
place it right back onto the stand now
one thing that I really like about the
magic keyboard case is how easy it is to
fold it down and take it with you so
just grab one hand
just like that fold it and you got it
just hold it by the hinge like that you
can just carry it like a book or
whatever else just like that's nice and
slim and it's actually not as heavy as
people make it out to be
now with this guy what you're gonna do
is you're gonna fold it down put the
flap down and then you can just grab it
like that this is definitely a lot more
thick I don't know if you guys can see
from there but that is definitely a
thick case now let's move on to
comparing the keyboards on these cases
so with the magic keyboard case using it
over the weekend I can tell you that
this is probably the best keys on any
keyboard case that I've ever used it's
actually comparable to those Mac books
which is really impressive for this
really thin keyboard case now the cool
thing about having the smart connector
on both of these is that it basically
has a hardwired connection so when
you're typing everything registered
instantly you don't have any lag like
you might have with a Bluetooth keyboard
where you're typing and it might show up
just a split-second afterwards and it
just kind of ruins the experience not
that bad but still it's much better to
have this instant key clicking and
everything with that smart connector now
of course you have the same thing on the
Logitech keyboard case because it has a
smart connector so definitely really
nice really responsive on the keyboard
now let's compare the sound of the keys
so listen to this so basically on the
Logitech it's more of like a standard
traditional keyboard where you actually
have a really nice amount of travel
maybe around the same or slightly more
travel than the magic keyboard case but
it does feel a little bit mushy whereas
with this keyboard case on the magic
keyboard you get more of a clicky feel
more tactile more more feedback I guess
on this keyboard and it's really quite
satisfying having that much key travel
but also having this
clicky feel on these keys so to be
honest if I was to choose one of these
keyboards just for the keys themselves I
would choose the magic keyboard for sure
it is
better than the logitech now of course
one of the perks that you get with the
logitech combo touch is the function
keys at the top so right here we have
the Escape key which if you double click
it it opens up your app switcher we have
brightness control so we have a keyboard
little pop-up which it'll pop up your
keyboard if you're typing you have a
spotlight search button you have the
backlighting which I'll get into right
after this the keyboard backlighting you
have media keys and of course a little
lock button I don't I don't know who's
gonna be using that that often but you
have it there just in case now for the
backlighting on the magic keyboard you
actually don't have any of those
function keys so a lot of people
complain about that but if you guys can
look from above like you see my fingers
are disappearing now imagine you had
another row up top you would be probably
like hitting the bottom of the iPad pro
with your hands trying to reach out for
that so maybe that's one of the reasons
why Apple didn't add it in and if you
look at the trackpad it's already really
really slim it is definitely not a big
trackpad now as far as backlighting this
is the really cool feature on the magic
keyboard case it actually takes the data
from the ambient light sensor the same
sensor that makes the auto brightness of
the display work it actually takes that
data and naturally when it gets darker
in your room when it gets towards the
evening the backlighting actually turns
on automatically by itself and I found
over the weekend that it stays at the
perfect level to where you would
actually want it to be able to see the
keys so let me show you for example I'm
gonna turn on my flashlight and put it
up to there so right now the keys are
not working at all and if I cover it
look at that I don't know if you guys
can tell from the top camera but they
just turned on and now put the
flashlight there you go they just turned
off so it's actually really cool to see
it working on the magic keyboard case
now for the trackpads I initially
thought that the one on the Logitech was
plastic but it's not it's glass just
like the one on the magic keyboard case
is glass as well but there is a major
difference between these two the
logitech uses a diving board kind of
mechanism for the trackpad which means
it's actually attached on the top so if
you're trying to click the top you
basically can't unless you're pushing as
hard as you can right but near the
bottom it's incredibly easy to tap and
as you get closer to the top like in the
middle it's already harder to click
really easy on the bottom but harder in
the middle and at the top it becomes a
lot more tough to click now with the
magic keyboard case
I don't know how Apple did this maybe
there's gonna be a teardown but you get
a perfectly even clicking feel all over
so that means if you're gonna be
clicking on your trackpads this is
definitely the one you want to go for
because you get a really nice easy
clicking feel even at the top the
corners anywhere definitely a hundred
percent the better trackpad and it feels
really smooth as well now you don't
necessarily have to click because if you
go into the settings into the trackpad
settings you can enable tap to click
works perfectly fine as a click and you
can also enable secondary click which is
with two fingers there you go you have a
right-click and probably the best thing
about the trackpad support is having
multi-touch gestures use three fingers
to swipe left and right between apps it
works really well
although I don't know why but the one on
the magic keyboard case seems more
responsive it's like it has better
reliability like every time I do it it
works whereas here look at that it kind
of skips a beat sometimes it doesn't
register now if we talk about how
premium each of these feel to be
completely honest even though you're
using this really nice Logitech combo
touch keyboard case it looks like a
basic old regular keyboard case because
you have the flap in the back it just
looks very standard
but with the magic keyboard case it
looks really modern first of all really
modern really premium because you see
the outline of the edges of the iPad pro
and for once this floating design which
i think is completely original totally
unique because if somebody sees this
this tablet floating they know it's an
iPad pro this just looks really
professional really sleek and modern now
before we get into the pricing in which
keyboard case I would recommend for you
to buy there is one extra feature on the
magic keyboard case oh I forgot one
thing this is not gonna fall off you can
hold it by the iPad pro you can hold it
by the keyboard case the magnetic
connection holding the iPad to the magic
keyboard case is very very strong now
this last feature is this USB C port
right here this is the first keyboard
case ever on any tablet where it comes
with a built-in charging port on the
case itself so I noticed a couple of
perks first of all you can plug in your
charger it charges it and I actually
tested it out and it seems to charge
just as quickly as using the regular
charger I'm not sure how they're able to
achieve it but the park is that you can
charge it on the keyboard case it works
through the smart connector and you
actually have the original USB C port on
the iPad pro available to hook up a
storage device flash drive whatever so
that way you don't have to buy one of
those little hubs where you plug it in
you have something sticking out the side
with the keyboard case you don't have to
get that you plug it into the back and
there you go you have that extra port
now the really cool thing that I noticed
that nobody really talked about was
having the charger plugged into the
keyboard case back here it stays out of
the way it's behind you barely even
notice that it's plugged in compared to
having it plugged in right here up on
the iPad pro it's just right there in
front of you is sticking out it's
definitely a huge perk compared to the
Logitech combo touch which you don't get
any of that on this keyboard case now
for the pricing a hundred and fifty
dollars for the Logitech $300 for the
magic keyboard case for the 11 inch iPad
pro doesn't matter if it's the
18 or the 2020 model 350 for the twelve
point nine inch now the way I see it is
that the people who are going to be
going for the budget iPad they don't
prioritize the quality of their tablets
as much as somebody who wants to go for
the iPad pro if you're buying the iPad
pro you're buying it for a reason you
want the best tablet out there because
it is really the best tablet you can get
you prioritize your tech now somebody
going for the 10.2 inch they're
completely fine with a budget tablet
with the a-10 chip the performance
that's all they want it for and that's
perfectly fine because I actually
recommended this set up the ten by two
inch iPad and this combo touch keyboard
case four for example small business
owners or students because having the
trackpad in the keyboard just completely
changes this tablet and it turns it into
a laptop replacement so that's really
nice
so if you go for this option you're
spending around four hundred and thirty
to four hundred and fifty bucks for this
entire set up compared to around eleven
hundred dollars plus for the magic
keyboard case and the iPad pro so what
I'm trying to say is the keyboard case
that you buy just depends on which one
you want to go for the iPad pro or the
regular iPad but to sum this whole video
up I just fell in love with a magic
keyboard case I have never just used an
iPad like this and had so much
functionality with this awesome trackpad
the best trackpad on any keyboard case
and the best keyboard the keys
themselves on any keyboard case as well
even though you don't have the function
keys it's actually really quick to
change the settings like the brightness
you just go up and two fingers just like
that you adjust it and then you just
swipe down really really quick so
there's no issue without those function
keys and just the overall feel that you
get with this floating design being able
to lift it off in an instant it's just
so nice on the magic keyboard case being
able to take it take it with you just
like that this is definitely the more
premium option even though it is
expensive I would recommend you guys try
this out and I think this is going to be
a total game changer for the iPad pro
going into the future I think a lot of
people are going to be buying
the magic keyboard case this is just the
ultimate the ultimat keyboard case
nothing can beat it especially with that
pass-through charging the automatic
keyboard backlighting this is just the
best apple experience I've felt in a
long time so there you guys have it that
was the comparison between these two
keyboard cases if you're interested in
buying one of these or buying the iPad
pro or the iPad I'm gonna have some
links the best sales on these devices
down in the description below so thank
you guys for watching and if you haven't
already seen our video on the magic
keyboard case check it out right over
there it talks about Apple's master plan
for the iPad pro so thank you guys
hopefully you enjoy this tap like down
below and click the circle above to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]